the general manager of the San Francisco
49ers calling in from Indianapolis where
the 49ers and Colts will have at it this
weekend in the technically final dress
rehearsal if you will full dress
rehearsal for the regular season for
which there are so many high hopes in
Niners country John Lynch back here on
the show how you doing John Rich I'm
doing great it's you know the season is
nearing and that's always fun and this
this third preseason game which everyone
refers to is that is the dress rehearsal
there's always kind of symbolic to me
about they this thing is getting close
and we've got a lot of evaluations it
didn't bring up we obviously want to
continue to get better as we as we near
this season and our opener in Minnesota
what does the walk me through what you
will be looking at evaluation wise
specifically what you're hoping to see
in week 3 of this preseason game yeah
well so this is this is one where our
starters will will play more than
they've been playing through our
preseason so I think this really is a
game you know I always remember as a
player you wanna you want to feel it you
want to go full-speed and you want to
kind of get extended snaps and see how
everyone everyone deals with that get in
football shape but then you know I think
we still have some competitions you know
at various positions going on on our
roster and so we're obviously gonna be
watching that closely and then you know
in my role now you watch the last five
minutes of the fourth quarter just as
closely because you know come making up
that 53 is just vital to the depth of
your team and and there's so many
different things that go into the
equation how guys playing on special
teams how how versatile a player is and
so you put them in these situations
because some guys perform very well at
practice but they get in a game and and
you know it's not not as good or some
guys the other way so I think there's so
many different variables to the to the
puzzle and we're looking at it just
about everything and then you expect to
see Richard Sherman out there this
weekend correct yeah and that's you know
we think in Houston we went down there
and scrimmaged and I think I saw I saw
my first dose of the real Richard
Sherman trying to keep him off the field
you know Kyle said it's your job you're
my muscle this week because Richards
bound and determined to just Anna and
I'm afraid he's just gonna go run on the
field because even though our medical
professionals were saying another week
Richard felt like he was ready so
keeping him off the field was was you
know you do many things as a general
manager that was me that was my task
last week what can you walk with son can
you say can you walk me through a little
bit of that Stanford on Stanford
conversation right there well you know
Kyle you know Kyle he asked for Sherm
asked for a meeting to come talk with
Kyle about it and Kyle invited me in
there he said I don't want to be in her
load with sure I know where he's going
and I said shoot let's bring skip no D
lineman we need some to me but you know
it's just Richards very convicted and he
felt like he was well but and and you
know the cool thing about it he felt
like and I remember this feeling when I
went to Denver after my 11th year in
Tampa you feel in a sense like you have
to prove yourself to your teammates and
you know I think well we tried too hard
on him is take that out of the equation
these guys already respect the head of
our success impact on them we need you
well for the regular season and we
understand that you have to get yourself
ready and you have a process but we feel
like the last two weeks he can he can
take care of that process and at some
point he trusted us and until four hours
later what he did and again it came back
at it and so it was constant but that's
that's what makes him a great place that
it's fun to see kind of what goes into
making people great and I've really
enjoyed being around Richard and seeing
everything that makes him tick 49ers GM
John Lynch right here on the Rich Eisen
show how good is Jimmy G John everybody
talks about seeing him up close and how
good he is and we saw just him and
deshaun Watson going at it and
preseason game was just a whole load of
fun but walk me through your your
evaluation your process of looking at
this kid and what we're expecting from
him well he's he's supremely talented I
mean when you just talk about arm Talent
it's it's pretty special from that
standpoint and you know I would tell you
that what kind of that you know when we
brought a man you Kyle studying them a
lot at Eastern Illinois you just turn on
the table yet limited limited
sample size you could see the arm talent
but what you want to see is everything
else and I think the best compliment I
could give him in the time that we were
around him last year was just he made
everyone better I think that's what
great players do great leaders do they
make people around them better and he
did that our defense played better when
he was our quarterback how that works I
don't know but it does and that's that's
what that's what guys who have the
ability to be special players do and you
know I think the you know they the
answer to that question how good is he I
think we're all going to see and you
know we we had to make a decision and we
felt really good about what we saw from
Jimmy in every aspect how he interacts
with the guys how he helped how
seriously he takes his craft how hard he
works at it and you know we're pushing
forward with it I'm you know I'm I'm
excited because I think the work that he
and Kyle have had this offseason to
really to get a hubbell grasp of the
odds of our offense I think it's going
to make them a better player and you
know I think everybody knows including
Jim that you know that the expectations
are big but what I like most about him
and I think it was ingrained into him
with how he was raised and then how he
was raised in the NFL at New Englanders
you got to go show everyone you got to
go go to work and that's what he does
each and every day and I had Peter King
here in studio a couple weeks ago John
and I turned to him I'm like will we
ever know why he was available for just
a second round draft choice in the
middle of the season
and he said only a handful of people
know the answer that question he said
the answers to that question people who
know they answer that question Isabella
Czech crafts
maybe Brady and he said John Lynch do
you know the answer to that question
John Lynch I don't I don't and I don't
spend a lot of time thinking about it
other than you know you know I'm
appreciative and and that that we had
the opportunity to bring a player in
like that and you know that everybody
says if you don't if you don't have that
guy at that position you're looking for
it and we certainly were looking for it
and you know we thought it would come
via different avenues you know we knew
that there was gonna be a good free
agency crop and that there were a lot of
guys in both our first draft and our
second drafts but we passed in our first
draft and we were kind of coming about
our business and the opportunity
presented itself and and we jumped at it
you know the thing I think that we did
we did well and it was probably Kyle
showing more restraint than me was a
just because we traded for Jimmy doesn't
mean that he's our guy moving forward
we're going to give we feel like it's
worth a second round pick to see is this
our guy and you know it was it was a
short amount of time to figure that out
but you know it was it was impactful the
time we spent around him and there was a
time where you know we both looked at
each other and said we need to do this
and and that's exactly what we did and
thankfully he was he was open to that
idea of of doing something long-term as
well and when was that point was it a
specific throw was there an aha moment
in the gang you in a practice and
anything John yeah I would tell you it
was probably I probably arrived a little
earlier Kyle Kyle's got a high standard
for quarterbacks he works with them
every day and you know I think it was
probably after the Tennessee game where
Kyle came in and said you know what this
kids pretty damn good could go ahead and
do this and and we flew down to LA and
met with his representative Don you
and just said listen we've got a bunch
of options at our disposal we can
franchise and we can do that whole thing
but that's not what we want to do you
know we're going to come strong with our
first offer to represent that we want to
do this thing and and we did and they
were open to that so that's kind of how
it went down
and then just one more question on this
subject before we move on to Pat Bowlen
because I know I'm sure you're gonna
have something to say on that front you
know I just love listen to his press
conference I could listen to him talk
football X's and O's all the time well
where does he rank with his dad on that
front do you think John he's a lot more
open and transparent I think his dad was
a little more old-school in his press
conferences but but you know that's a
snapshot of basically why I hitch my
wagon to him you know when looking for a
job in in this side of football but I
had always had been introduced to it a
little by watching my friend John Elway
do it and said well if the right
opportunity ever came up I would love to
do this the right opportunity to me back
then always meant okay if it happened to
tap I or Denver or back then San Diego
where where I was from something that
just made a lot of sense for my family
but then you know this situation kind of
happened with Kyle where I thought he
was going to get the job I had been
doing a lot of his games and every time
I talk to him it's like one of those
press conferences where you learn
football and you know I think we would
have great dialogue and and you know he
later tells me he would learn for me I
would I would learn from him and we just
you know I was always really engaged
when I talked football with him the part
I would tell you that I didn't know
because you don't see that part is like
how does he command a team how does and
that's where he's been off the charts
good to me as well so you know I think
we've got a tremendous head coach in
Kyle for years to come and now we all
you know it's great to think all these
things now we got it all go do it you
know and there's we've got a great
opportunity this season to do just that
couple more minutes left with John Lynch
40
honors general manager you have the
floor on Pat Bowlen being named a
contributor finalist for enshrinement in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame and why
you believe that is deserving John well
first of all for both mr. B and Gil
Brandt I mean I was wrong about you guys
you just had a huge impact on this
league and you know I got to experience
a pole and I used to I used to see him
all the time in Beaver Creek Colorado
we'd go ski in there for Christmas and
the Bowens would always be the or after
Christmas excuse me I was playing at the
time but you know as soon as the season
was over and the Poland's would always
be up there so that's really how I
started to get to know mr. Bolen spent
spent some time up there with him and
you know one of the great stories was
when I signed as a free agent with the
Broncos mr. B you know was thrilled we
had a press conference did the whole
deal and then I got called up to his
office and he said you know I've really
enjoyed getting to know you over the
years here in Beaver Creek and we always
talked about maybe this come under
fruition you plant you becoming a Bronco
and we've done that now but here's the
deal no more schemes for the box but not
the Broncos is that what he said
basically yeah and don't even try it
because I've got a lot of sources I got
a lot of people and I know every time
one of our guys you know what I did I
skied in Montana the thing with mr. B is
like a lot of places and I don't think
it's lip service of course everyone
wants to win championships that was what
he was all about was winning and given
his team an opportunity each and every
year to do that and he was always it
helps me a lot to this take that he was
always there as an owner you know
showing his presence but never meddled
let people do their work just a
tremendous person and I think it's long
overdue and and yeah I think he belongs
in
oh yeah I was a that was a I had a big
smile on my face when I saw that
yesterday so do you John you belong
there I know you can't say anything and
he's getting in response to that but
it'd be great if the two you guys going
together next year so I just say that
out there and then I've got one last
question for you on the helmet rule you
general manager former defensive back
how do you think this is playing out so
far in the preseason John yeah so you
know the best thing I saw on that was
Belichick hoo-ee as a way of saying
things and I saw a quote where he said
look it's not my job to like it or not
like it it's my job to understand it and
teach it and you know I I agree
wholeheartedly with that I would I would
say that I think where we're all trying
to figure it out is is the understand
part I think everyone's a little you
know yes the written language is there
but how are they going to enforce it and
I think everyone's feeling their way I
think adjustments as we saw earlier this
week I think a little bit of an
adjustment to how it's going to be
called but you know I haven't been
around the league you see these things
before I don't know as drastic of this
but in it they have a way of figuring
themselves out I think and so where
everyone's just looking for clarity and
then it's everyone's job to adhere to it
I was in the in the room at the owners
meetings when I kind of came to bear and
you know there I can't can't tell you
that there wasn't part of me though and
while it's gonna change the game forever
and we go we better be careful but
that's that's what everyone decided to
do and so now it's you got to teach it
and you know we have a lot of guys on
our staff
Robert Sala from from you know came from
the Seahawks and you know he had
previously worked with detail they teach
that rugby style so we we've already
been teaching it but you know as I used
to say sometimes when I would get fined
as a player you to whoever was here in
my appeal you do know that your head is
attached to your body sometimes these
things are unavoidable but you got to do
your best and everyone I think striving
to do that John you are the best thanks
for the time thanks for the calm I know
you got a Sunday night game against the
Rams coming up so I mean that's in San
Francisco I'm trying to see if you're
gonna be down here in
Los Angeles taking on the Chargers maybe
you'd love to see yeah we doing with
charges at some point but I'd love to
see you yeah we'll stop by that'd be fun
I'd be great John you take care okay
Riggs John Lynch general manager the
Niners here in the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience